Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Heute sind wir mal äh nicht in einem Studio. Trotzdem, die fünfzehnte Ausgabe von Lokbuchen Netzpolitik äh kommt mehr oder weniger pünktlich hier an den Start und äh ja, dank äh unserer lieben Bundesregierung,
keinen Themenmangel, da wurde dann am Wochenende noch frisch eingegossen. Was ist denn passiert?
Ja, die Koalition hat das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Presseverlage irgendwie auf ihre Agenda gehoben und möchte jetzt dafür sorgen, dass ein solches möglichst schnell eingeführt wird.
Ein Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ein Leistungsschutzrecht in Abgrenzung zum Urheberrecht, auch wenn es dann in der ersten Meldung bei Bild DE sofort hieß, die Koalition verbessert jetzt das Urheberrecht. Es geht dabei irgendwie darum, dass Presseverlage ein
ähnlichen Schutz wir Urheber für die ihre Erzeugnisse haben wollen, weil die
Erzeugnisse selber, die Schriften, die da veröffentlicht werden, ja eigentlich schon ein Urheberrecht unterliegen. Und irgendwie wollen die Verlage jetzt auch noch ein schönes Recht haben. Und wie es dazu kam,
sie sich damit erhoffen und warum das wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee ist.
Uns heute der Philipp Otto erklären, der ist nämlich,
Iroids Info und in der Initiative für.
Nee, gegen Initiative, gegen einen Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage aktiv. Schönen guten Morgen Philipp.
Einen wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Vielleicht sollten wir auch noch einen kurzen Ton sagen zufo, als solchen, das ist vielleicht manchen, aber nicht unbedingt allen bekannt. Philipp, vielleicht erklärst du mal kurz selber, was noch zu dem Projekt.
Genau, gerne. Also Info ist äh seit vielen Jahren eine Informationsplattform zum Urheberrecht, wo wir insbesondere versuchen, äh Verbraucher, aber auch kreativ schaffende darüber aufzuklären,
erlaubt ist und was verboten ist und äh gerade in den Zeiten, in denen jetzt viele Gesetzesänderungen im Urheberrecht anstehen, haben wir natürlich auch sehr, sehr viel aktuelle Politik und Stimmen dort auf der Seite.
Mhm. Ich hatte ja auch mit ähm Matthias Spielkamp, der ja auch bei euch im äh Team ist, also schreiben ja eine ganze Menge Autoren,
CAE jetzt spezifisch zum Thema Urheberrecht gemacht, CAI hundertvierundsechzig, da sah jetzt nochmal drauf, äh,
aber du hast dich jetzt speziell auf dieses Leistungsschutzrecht drauf gestürzt.
Genau.
Ja und was äh wie was ist denn so aus deiner Sicht passiert?
Also das Leistungsschutzrecht äh für Presseverlage ist eine Forderung, die seit zirka zweieinhalb Jahren von den,
Verlagen und dort insbesondere von den,
großen Verbänden, BDZV und VDZ erhoben wird. Äh sie haben's geschafft, äh nach der letzten Bundestagswahl
Dieses äh die Forderung nach einem Leistungsschutzrecht in den schwarz-gelben Koalitionsvertrag reinzu
zu schreiben oder reinschreiben zu lassen. Seitdem äh schlummert es auf der politischen Agenda und ist äh seit zwei, zweieinhalb Jahren hochumstritten, äh
insbesondere auch vor dem Hintergrund, da keiner eigentlich genau weiß, was das sein soll, äh was ein solches Recht beinhalten soll, was für Folgen das hat,
Und jetzt am letzten Sonntag hat der Koalitionsausschuss getagt, der Bundesregierung
insbesondere auch wieder Handlungsfähigkeit zu beweisen,
den ganzen anderen Geschichten von Wulf und Co. Und einer der Punkte, wo Handlungsfähigkeit bewiesen werden soll
ist, dass tatsächlich jetzt dieses Leistungsschutzrecht, das manche schon für tot erklärt hatten, äh,
aufleben soll und jetzt äh im Urheberrechtsgesetz verankert werden soll.
Und ähm gibt's denn da jetzt irgendwas Neues oder ist das jetzt eigentlich so das, was da schon immer diskutiert wurde äh und das wird jetzt einfach mal mit wir wollen das jetzt auch mal beschließen, reingeschrieben.
Naja, es ist im Prinzip äh der Tanz um den heißen Brei, äh da eigentlich niemand weiß, was da drin stehen soll und wird. Äh die Presseverleger haben äh
in im Laufe der letzten zwei Jahre äh im regelmäßigen Rhythmus äh auch ihre Forderungen verändert und auch ständig äh das, was sie potenziell wollen mit so einem Recht äh die Argumente dafür verändert
das weiß man sozusagen auch von der Seite nicht, was sie sich genau vorstellen
weiß man auch von Seiten der Bundesregierung nicht genau äh,
was da jetzt drin stehen soll, ob sie den Presseverlegern komplett entgegenkommen
oder äh möglicherweise eine abgeschwächte Form in das Gesetz reinschreiben wollen,
Das ist äh zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch offen. Äh deswegen äh hat sich äh zu dem,
Ausgangspunkt äh nicht so viel verändert. Die Veränderung wird dann kommen, wenn wir wissen, okay, das ist jetzt der Gesetzestext,
Das und das soll geregelt werden und das könnte die und die Folgen haben,
dann hat man die Veränderung. Aber was bisher eben äh immer noch der Status quo ist, ist äh eine riesige Verunsicherung. Äh bei auf allen Seiten und die geht von der Wirtschaft, also
auch die Verbände Bitcom oder BDI haben sich heftigst dagegen ausgesprochen bis hin zu der ganzen Netz- und Blockwelt weil hier auch schwerste Kollateralschäden befürchtet.
Welches welche Leistung wollen Sie sich denn jetzt genau in welcher Form schützen? Du sagst schon, dass sich das relativ häufig geändert hat, aber irgendwie einen Kern muss es ja geben, was Sie jetzt für sich als ihre schützenswerte Leistung erachten.
Naja, die Presseverlage sagen, das äh was Sie machen
im Prinzip das Zusammenführen von Nachrichten, das Betreuen der Redaktion, et cetera,
ist allein schon so eine Leistung, dass sie ein eigenes Schutzrecht brauchen, ein Schutzrecht, äh das über ihre bisherigen Rechte,
hinweg geht
Dazu muss man wissen, ähm die Presseverlage lassen sich regelmäßig,
durch sogenannte Verträge von freien Journalisten oder eben im Rahmen der
Angestellten Journalisten sämtliche Rechte äh für jegliche Verwertung,
in der Folge auch äh der Rechtsverfolgung abtreten
sie verfügen über diese ganzen Rechte, um gegen potentielle Kopien, äh die bis heute nicht richtig bewiesen sind et cetera vorzugehen,
Sie brauchen an diesem Punkt äh ein solches Recht überhaupt nicht
wollen's aber trotzdem haben und dies äh vor dem Hintergrund, dass äh sie irgendeine Handhabe äh dagegen haben wollen, dass es beispielsweise erfolgreiche Geschäftsmodelle äh gibt, wie Aggregatoren, äh,
Beispiel ganz klar Google News äh wo gesagt wird, okay ähm.
Hier ist ein Bereich, da wollen wir gerne partizipieren,
schaffen es nicht, auf unseren eigenen Webseiten
Geld für für Journalismus oder für diese Inhalte zu generieren,
schafft das ja oder andere schaffen das ja. Also wollen wir hier ein Teil des Kuchens abhaben,
So eine Argumentation ist in sich total unschlüssig und damit sollte man sie auch nicht durchkommen lassen.
Also Google News ist ja die Sparte von Google, bei der ich in,
Nachrichten suchen kann. Und ich weiß, dass es damals ein,
relativ
schwieriges Unterfangen war, Netzpolitik ORG da überhaupt reinzubekommen. Ja, ich musste eine spezielle Seitmap für Google machen und äh also im, im Gegensatz zu der normalen Zeitmaps sieht die irgendwie anders aus
und äh musste dann meine Seite aktiv dort anmelden und denen sagen, schaut doch mal, ob wir uns da mit einnehmen, äh mit aufnehmen möchtet. Und dann haben wir irgendwann von Google die Antwort bekommen. Uns wurde gesagt, ja
euch nehmen wir in Google News auf. Also
Das ist ja jetzt alles andere als ein ein bösarter Gregator, der irgendwie vorbeikommt. Ich musste wirklich,
Ähm ich hatte einen Tag Arbeit damit, äh mich da überhaupt äh mit Netzpolitik org äh,
irgendwie überhaupt da reinzukommen in dieses Google News
und ähm jetzt wundert's mich so ein bisschen, dass man sagt,
denen möchten wir das jetzt verbieten oder davon möchten von dem Kuchen, den die da vermeintlich haben, möchten wir ein Stück abhaben.
Ja, ich äh, das sehe ich genauso. Ich finde diese Vorstellung auch ähm völlig absurd äh in den Reaktionen, äh die jetzt auch nach der Entscheidung ähm des Koalitionsausschusses
wurde das ja auch nochmal deutlich äh im Prinzip äh tut Google News den Verlagen was Gutes
in dem Google News die Nutzer dort auf die Seiten der Verlage, insbesondere auch der kleinen Verlage, der regionalen Verlage
beziehungsweise regionalen Angebote der großen Verlage lenkt. Äh und äh nicht andersrum.
Und äh das hat äh Mario Sixtus äh im vergangenen Jahr,
damit äh verglichen, ähm dass äh im Prinzip.
Ähm der äh Restaurantbesitzer von dem Taxifahrer jetzt noch Geld verlangt, dass er ihm die Kunden bringt. Und im Prinzip
ist das äh Synonym das Gleiche, was die Presseverlage hier tun.
Ähm ja, es ist äh sozusagen kompliziert äh
auch in Google News reinzukommen, weil Google News da auch 'ne Wertung vornimmt, was ist denn jetzt 'ne Nachrichtenseite, was soll denn da rein? Nicht jede Seite soll da rein
aber sie versuchen das nach meiner Kenntnis, ich bin da nicht dabei und hab da keine Ahnung auch nicht wie die genauen Kriterien sind, äh versuchen wir sie das schon so zu machen, dass äh
im Prinzip die relevanten Seiten dort auch zu finden sind.
Was mich so ein bisschen verwirrt ist, von welchem Kuchen reden sie denn da eigentlich? Ich meine, auf Google News gibt es keine Werbung, man muss dafür nicht bezahlen. Ähm,
Ich sehe da überhaupt gar keine Einnahmequelle, die sie da jetzt äh geltend machen können. Also.
Genau, das ist im Prinzip sozusagen der sekundäre Effekt, der dort äh abgeschöpft werden soll
ist richtig, auf Google News gibt's keine Werbung und Google News findet direkt keine Wertschöpfung statt, aber natürlich stärkt so ein Angebot wie Google News, die Gesamtmarke Google und Google weiß äh oder es ist auch überall bekannt, äh dass Google sehr, sehr viel
mit der Werbung und äh hier sagen die Verlage, okay hier wollen wir was abhaben. Ich finde die Begründung auch an Haaren herbeigezogen und bislang konnte mir auch noch niemand von den Verlagen wirklich erklären, äh wie dieser Widerspruch ausgeräumt werden soll.
Also was glaube ich noch ganz wichtig zu erwähnen ist, also Google News, wenn ich da jetzt äh drauf gehe, dann bekomme ich die,
bekomme ich quasi die Schlagzeilen. Da drunter steht dann die Seite und irgendwie ein kurzer Ausschnitt aus dem. Also Google klaut da jetzt nicht die die gesamten Artikel, sondern ähm ich,
Google zeigt mir, wer hat grade was sind gerade die Top News und wo finde ich die? Und dann werden auch die Artikel ein bisschen zusammen sortiert, also jetzt sehe ich gerade irgendwie einen von der und,
andere Artikel zu diesem Thema in anderen Publikationen werden dem dann ein bisschen ähm dazu sortiert, so dass quasi aus vielen
Nachrichtenseiten einem mir zusammen aggregiert wird und ich da so ein bisschen den Überblick bekomme,
was so in allen Zeitungen steht. Eine andere Sache, die es ja gibt, ähm,
River. Das ist ja im Prinzip das Gleiche. Ähm,
nur mit ein bisschen anderen Informationsquellen,
verdient, glaube ich, das ist der Frank Westfal, der das macht.
Verdient hier Geld, dadurch dass er sein Projekt da gesponsert bekommt.
Also das heißt, er wäre dann im Zweifelsfall auch betroffen. Das wäre also sein River könnte er in dieser Form nicht mehr weiter betreiben. Wenn da jetzt auf einmal alle Verlage sagen, wir haben aber jetzt hier ein Schutzrecht und wenn du auf uns verlinkst,
dann äh musst du uns Geld geben.
Genau, da ist es am offensichtlichsten. Äh da handelt's sich äh sozusagen um diese berühmtberüchtigten Snippets, die auch bei Google News oder bei River oder bei Turi oder bei wem auch immer angezeigt werden.
Das Problem ist hier aber, dass es nicht nur diese Angebote betrifft,
Ziel zwar dadrauf insbesondere auf Google, weil man dort Geld vermutet und da teilhaben will,
man erwischt ganz viele,
Nach allem, was man aktuell weiß, ist, äh dass auch äh kleinste Teile,
von diesen Snippets rechtlich geschützt werden sollen, was bisher nicht der Fall ist.
Ist bisher völlig Urheberrechtskonform, das zu verwenden. Und wenn man jetzt diese kleinsten Teile nimmt,
wo niemand genau weiß, wie viel das ist. Äh die Verlage haben teilweise auch schon davon gesprochen, dass die Formulierungen von bestimmten Überschriften geschützt werden sollen,
Wenn man das macht, dann betrifft das natürlich sehr, sehr viele,
Personen, insbesondere alle die Blogs anbieten, alle die dort auf Presseartikel verlinken,
Möglicherweise betrifft das auch das Einstellen äh oder verlinken von Nachrichten auf Facebook möglicherweise auch auf Twitter. Ähm,
Das ist ein komplett offenes Feld. Das einzigste Kriterium, äh was im Prinzip der Gesetzgeber nach allem, was wir aktuell wissen,
einziehen will ist, dass man sagt, ja, es geht aber,
nur um die gewerbliche Nutzung und nicht um die private,
Jetzt haben wir aber das Problem im Urheberrecht, äh dass der Begriff gewerblich nicht wirklich definiert ist, beziehungsweise wenn es sich um eine gewerbliche Nutzung handelt,
dann ist diese sehr, sehr weit, heißt schon bei dem geringsten Anteil äh von,
Kommerzialität äh kann schon von gewerblich gesprochen werden. Was das sein soll, ist völlig unklar.
Also zum Beispiel unser, unser Podcast hier, der ja auch regelmäßig auf äh solche Artikel verweist und einen Flitterbutton hat, der ist dann schon ausreichend gewerblich und wir dürften dann schon gar nicht mehr drauf verlinken.
Genau, das äh ist ein Szenario, dass nicht ganz undenkbar ist. Es ist unglaublich, das kommt, wie gesagt, wir haben diesen Entwurf noch nicht, aber,
muss damit gerechnet werden, dass auch genau sowas unter gewerblich fällt,
Das ist dann beispielsweise ein Flatterbutton, das ist äh die Werbung bei Netzpolitik äh Punkt ORG, das ist äh eine kleinste Form von ähm von ähm,
dem Anschein, äh was gewerblich sein könnte. Und ähm was das genau und konkret dann ist, äh da wird der Gesetzgeber auch nichts dazu sagen,
ähm das äh Gesetz wird nicht so konkret sein aller Voraussicht.
Dass das drinsteht, heißt das müssen Gerichte dann entscheiden,
Die Gerichte entscheiden im Einzelfall, hieße, wenn das kommt und die Gerichte das entscheiden müssen, werden wir über einen sehr langen Zeitraum,
eine große Vielzahl von unterschiedlichen gerichtlichen Entscheidungen haben, was denn im Einzelfall jetzt als gewerblich,
anzustufen ist und was nicht. Beziehungsweise was jetzt ein kleiner Teil ist und was nicht,
wiedergegebenen Beitrag und dann hat man so die den klassischen Bereich der rechtsunsicherheit, der riesig ist mit allen Folgen das möglicherweise im Voraus,
Angebote abgeschafft werden, dass andere Projekte nicht an Staat gehen, weil man denkt, oh, man weiß ja nicht, wie die Rechtslage da ist,
beziehungsweise dass eine Vielzahl von Abmahnungen.
Das hängt dann ein Stück weit auch nochmal von der Ausgestaltung ab und wer wie
dann diese Rechte vertritt, ob das jetzt zum Beispiel auch 'ne Verwertungsgesellschaft macht oder nicht aber da ist ein riesen Bereich ein Rechtsunsicherheit drin, der uns hier droht. Das und das ist ein riesen Problem an dem Punkt.
Ist denn auch, also ähm vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen die Gerüchteküche äh auch gleich nochmal mit aufzuarbeiten, weil es ein bisschen unklar, hier ist ja irgendwie alles unklar, ja, aber was ich auch gehört habe, ist das auch etwas im Gespräch ist, wie so eine pauschale Abgabe, insbesondere jetzt bei der
möglichen kommerziellen Nutzungen von Firmen, die jetzt äh dieser Artikel,
im Netz lesen, ist da was dran oder ist das jetzt nur Gerüchtelage?
Hm, das ist äh meiner Meinung nach eine Gerüchtelage. Äh natürlich ähm.
Und das machen die Verlage ja auch schon, äh dass sie äh von Firma zu Firma rennen und versuchen ähm Vorverträge und Vereinbarungen abzuschließen über eine potenzielle Nutzung beziehungsweise pauschale Vergütung von
Also dass man beispielsweise
mit der Deutschen Bank. Jetzt ist einfach ein fiktives Beispiel mit der Deutschen Bank spricht und sagt, hier,
uns in Betrag X. Dafür ist das dann in Ordnung, äh dass ihr äh,
nach äh diesen Vorschriften, äh die dann kommen, ähm,
Texte behandelt. Sowas äh passiert und ähm.
Es ist aber im Endeffekt ein Gerücht, ob das im Gesetz drinsteht oder nicht. Ich glaube, dass es nicht drin steht.
Was versprachen die sich denn jetzt eigentlich davon? Ich meine, bisher äh höre ich eigentlich nur Sachen, die dazu führen, dass die Leute
ihre Dienste einstellen irgendwie, am Ende wird noch Google News Deutschland abgeschaltet, könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Das ist denkbar.
Wem ist denn damit jetzt eigentlich geholfen?
Prinzip ist niemanden damit geholfen außer,
den Verlagen, wie sie selber meinen, aber auch ich glaube
die Verlage schießen sich hier auch ins eigene Knie
weil das was ihn an Aufmerksamkeit durch eine mögliche Abschaltung,
von Google News beispielsweise, wie du sie gerade angesprochen hast, folgen würde. Ähm,
Das ist unabsehbar, was da passiert. Und äh ich sehe nicht,
wo die Verlage ähm davon profitieren können,
und wenn sie profitieren, dann sind das ganz, ganz wenige und das sind die Platzhirsche,
die großen Angebote von Springer und Burda,
Aber die äh sind im Netz eh erfolgreich,
zwar nicht unbedingt mit Journalismus, aber durchaus auch mit Werbung und mit ganz vielen anderen Mehrwertangeboten, die sie äh in ihrem Firmenkonsercium drin haben und die verdienen richtig viel Geld im Netz,
und den Verlagen ähm, denen es eigentlich möglich oder denen's idealerweise auch zugute kommen könnte, da sind die kleinen Verlage, denen nur das überhaupt nichts bringen.
Also eine Regionalzeitung ähm wird überhaupt nicht davon profitieren. Die kriegt höchstens Leser weggenommen.
Gilt denn das jetzt alles nur für Print?
Naja, das das gilt äh für äh Nachrichten, äh die im Netz verfügbar sind.
Also genauso gut auch Fernsehen und Audio. Und ähm was
könnt ihr das jetzt für Konsequenzen haben? Also ich also immer noch so ein bisschen schleierhaft,
was sie sich jetzt sozusagen eigentlich konkret davon äh versprechen, also entstehen da jetzt irgendwo Mehreinnahmen oder ist es mehr so eine Konkurrenzvermeidung.
Ich glaube, es ist äh ein ganz wesentlicher Teil ist äh davon äh der Konkurrenzkampf.
Zwischen den Verlagen und Google, der ja auch auf anderen Ebenen geführt wird,
Insbesondere auch kartellrechtlich. Bei Info hatten wir vergangene Woche. Auch darüber berichtet, dass die äh
Verlage, äh eine Kartellbeschwerde vor dem Bundeskartellamt äh gegen Google jetzt zurückgezogen haben. Die Gründe sind unklar und das auf europäischer Ebene jetzt nochmal weiterverfolgen. Äh und ähm.
In dieser Kartellbeschwerde ging's eben auch dadrum, dass gesagt würde, ja, ähm hier ist keine faire Beteiligung äh.
Google äh da und ähm Google missbrauche eine,
Markt beherrschende Stellung. Es gibt da jetzt keine Entscheidung dazu, ob das so ist oder nicht ist. Äh Fakt ist, dass diese Beschwerde zurückgezogen.
In dem Zusammenhang haben wir mit äh Justus Howkap,
ein Interview geführt ist Professor an der Uni Düsseldorf.
Äh Vorsitzender der Monopolkommission der Bundesregierung,
zum Kartellrecht, also das wichtigste, unabhängige Beratungs,
der Bundesregierung in diesem Bereich und er meinte ja.
Er sieht auch nicht, dass die Verlage hier große Chancen haben über den Weg des Kartellrechtes ranzukommen. Ähm er sieht vielmehr,
hat das so ein bisschen ausdifferenziert und hat gesagt, ja, es gibt immer äh zwei Strategien und zum Erfolg äh zu kommen. Das eine ist eine Marktstrategie,
und das andere ist 'ne nicht Marktstrategie, die Marktstrategie sagt OK ich versuche ein Produkt besser zu machen und so gut zu machen, dass es eben konkurrenzfähig ist,
und auf der anderen Seite die Nicht-Markt-Strategie, das ist, ich versuche das über andere Wege,
mir meine Rahmenbedingungen für dieses Produkt äh zu verbessern und die Verleger ähm.
Verfolgen hier ganz klar die zweite Strategie, indem sie sagen, okay, wir wollen hier ähm,
durch massiven Einsatz von Lobbyismus, diesen äh dieses Gesetz äh das Leistungsschutzrecht,
einführen, um unsere potenzielle Situation zu verbessern,
Ich glaube nicht, dass es die Situation verbessern wird,
wie ich auch grad schon gesagt hatte, aber die Verleger glauben das bis heute.
Steif und fest. Äh ich bin gespannt, was da passiert.
Was wären die, also es wird ja schon davon, werden das jetzt angekündigt oder so anklingen lassen, äh Google News Deutschland könnte dicht machen, River könnte platt gehen, ähm.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik.
Wir auch, wir sind auch dann bald fertig. Christoph Käse höchstpersönlich,
uns dann beerdigen als äh Podcast. Ähm also das wären quasi die
die schlimmsten Befürchtungen, die man an der Stelle jetzt haben könnte.
Na, es gibt noch eine weitere und das ist eine ganz grundsätzliche. Ähm grundsätzlich ist die Nachricht an sich, also es passiert irgendwo etwas. Diese Nachricht ist nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt. Die
entfernt von Urheberrechten, die ist frei. Wenn man aber jetzt äh,
Leistungsschutzrecht einführt äh und ein Schutz auf äh die Nachricht an sich legt,
das, äh dass man die Verkündung der Nachricht mit einem Schutzrecht,
verbindet, hieße, damit beschädigt man die Informationsfreiheit. Äh und würde den freien Zugang zur Information einschränken, ganz.
Dann könnten wir aber doch wahrscheinlich von Bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen.
Genau
Genau. Ich halte dieses Vorgehen, wenn das kommen sollte, tatsächlich auch für verfassungswidrig und äh es würden garantiert auch Leute diesen Weg,
reiten, äh dass sie das äh feststellen lassen würden oder versuchen fest feststellen zu lassen, ähm hieße aber, eine weitere rechtliche Auseinandersetzung
in einem Bereich äh und das hat sich vorher schon kurz angesprochen, der bis dahin ein riesiger Graubereich ist, wo niemand weiß, was darf ich jetzt, was darf ich nicht,
und das ist natürlich,
im bisherigen Urheberrecht schon so, äh dass das der größte Handschuh ist, dass keiner mehr äh diese Gesetze versteht und niemand mehr eigentlich weiß, was man darf und was man nicht darf.
Ja äh es macht ja auch so den Eindruck, als ob schon so alle ihre Geschütze auch ordentlich in Stellung äh bringen. Ich denke, so der der Widerstand im Netz, der dürfte mal so als,
sein, das hat sich ja auf Twitter schon gestern äh stark abgezeichnet. Ähm,
vierundsechzig hat jetzt auch äh sich schon dazu geäußert und lehnt das ab. Ähm hat das, ich meine,
Ich freue mich, muss man das eigentlich ernst nehmen? Ich meine, hat das überhaupt eine eine politische ähm Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit? Ich frage mich auch gerade, was eigentlich die Koalition an der Stelle da äh treibt. Also was denken die sich eigentlich?
Na, das ist das alte Spiel von äh
wem gebe ich was, damit er zufrieden ist? Ähm das ist äh neulich unter der Hand,
von einem ungenannten Vertreter der Verlagswirtschaft ist gefallen der Satz ja
nur dass das klar ist, wir sind hier die stärkste Lobby in Deutschland,
und wenn die Presseverlage das von sich selber sagen, dann gehen sie natürlich äh mit einer entsprechenden hohen Nase in die Verhandlung,
wissen genau wie abhängig die Politik von der Berichterstattung ist und.
Auch hier sind Fälle bekannt
die man jetzt nicht namentlich kennzeichnen kann aktuell,
wo ähm hochrangige Vertreter ähm des politischen Berlins ähm,
mittelmäßig äh bis kräftiger unter Druck gesetzt wurden, da ja alle sich äh durchaus doch freuen, wenn über sie positiv berichtet werden würde. Und ähm diesen Druck, den man da aufbaut, der macht anfällig
Entscheidungen
zu fällen, wo man vielleicht sagt, okay, die Griechenlandkrise ist vielleicht viel wichtiger in dem Moment.
Der Euro muss gerettet werden oder sonst irgendwas. Das Urheberrecht, das ist ja nur ein Randthema,
Und hier wird eben verkannt, äh dass dieser ganze Bereich des Urheberrechts und die Frage des Zugangs,
der Vergütung, der Verwaltung von digitalen Werken,
dass das einer der ganz wesentlichen Hebel und ein wesentliches Moment der Regulierung der zukünftigen Wertschöpfung im Netz ist,
und ähm das ist, glaube ich, noch nicht überall angekommen, welche Relevanz das hat,
Presseverlage wissen das. Äh drum äh setzen diese sie da so viel rein, dass das durchkommt. Und ich glaube, es ist aktuell für sie eine sehr bittere Erfahrung zu merken
Ist es das erste Mal, äh dass sie mit ihren Anliegen nicht einfach durchrauschen können durch ein Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Dass da erheblicher Widerstand da ist. Äh und es sehr viele Leute gibt, die das kritisch sehen und
das bringt dann im Endeffekt auch die Politik wieder in eine,
neue Situation, die durchaus auch schwierig für sie ist, weil sie sich plötzlich in einem Bereich entscheiden müssen, in dem sie sich möglicherweise noch nie entscheiden
und zwar, dass sie denen, die positiv über sie schreiben oder schreiben sollten,
möglicherweise etwas nicht geben können, was diese wollen.
Ja, da können sich vielleicht also der Axel-Springer-Verlag als einer, der am stärksten dafür lobbyierenden Verlage äh sich jetzt vielleicht doch nochmal ärgern, dass sie gerade den Politikern den Wulf ab
haben. Ähm weil jetzt die Politiker vielleicht erstmal nicht mehr so ein Interesse haben äh denen in in jeder Form entgegen zu kommen, auch wenn's gerade ein bisschen anders aussieht
was ist denn deine Prognose jetzt für die nächsten Monate? Also wann wird's da was konkreteres zu geben? Ähm wie sind da jetzt die nächsten geplanten Schritte? Wie wie muss ich da jetzt der
Protest, von dem du sprichst, äh worauf muss der sich jetzt da einstellen? Auf welchen ähm auf welchen Zeitraum blicken wir da? Ähm welche Meilensteine gibt's da in den nächsten Monaten?
Das ist ein Stück weit schwierig zu prognostizieren vielleicht zunächst mal der formale Weg,
haben jetzt äh das positive Votum äh des Koalitionsausschusses
Jetzt äh wird äh dieser Entwurf ähm an die beteiligten Ministerien äh zur Mitberatung gegeben
ähm hier muss dann abgewartet werden, ob,
beispielsweise neben dem Justizministerium, auch das Wirtschaftsministerium und ein anderes Ministerium noch Einwände hat,
ähm wenn dies nicht der Fall sein sollte, wovon auszugehen ist.
Ähm dann äh wird äh aus diesem Referentenentwurf äh ein Kabinettsentwurf dieser Kabinettsentwurf wird dann veröffentlicht und geht dann äh in den Gesetzgebungsprozess des Bundestages mit erster, zwoter, dritter Lesung et cetera,
das ist also so ganz grob der formale wie.
Zeitlich stattfinden wird, ist relativ offen,
Das kann sehr schnell passieren tatsächlich, weil äh der Druck äh hochgezogen wird,
kann aber und da gibt's auch Vermutungen, äh selbst aus der Koalition gibt's diese Vermutung, dass das sich noch eine Weile hinzieht und möglicherweise vor dem Sommer,
nichts mehr wird, äh dass das im Parlament liegt.
Aber das ist offen. Gerade auch diese,
aktuellen Proteste und die vielen Meldungen jetzt auch im Zuge von ACDA,
wo wir wissen, das hat die Politik so ein bisschen aufgeschreckt und es wurde davon gesprochen, ja, da hat man ja nie was davon gehört,
Das gab's ja dann quasi erst seit zwei Wochen und dann musste man's ernst nehmen. Die gleiche Situation hat man hier wieder
seit zweieinhalb Jahren wird äh hier äh,
arbeitet und versucht aufzuklären, auch in bei der Politik aufzuklären.
Die allermeisten Abgeordneten wissen aber noch überhaupt nichts von diesem Leistungsschutzrecht, beziehungsweise können das auch überhaupt nicht einschätzen. Ähm,
das kommt jetzt langsam an, dort und dann muss man gucken, wie stellen sich die einzelnen Fraktionen im Bundestag dazu, ähm gibt es hier eine Opposition?
Geschlossen dagegen steht oder nicht. Wie ist das äh mit potenziellen Abweichlern aus der Regierung,
wir wissen von etlichen Abgeordneten auch aus aus der Regierung.
Äh dass sie sich vehement gegen den Leistungsschutzrecht einsetzen und das ablehnen,
ein Beispiel ist hier auch zu nennen, zum Beispiel Jimmy Schulz von der FDP, er hat deutlich gemacht, dass er seiner Ministerin hier widerspricht und ähm sich dagegen einsetzt, äh dass die Bundesregierung,
später dieses Gesetz auch verabschieden kann.
Ist also sehr schwierig zu sagen, äh welche Faktoren äh da jetzt kommen,
und was beschleunigen könnte und was diese ganze Sache verlangsamen können.
Klar ist, je mehr Zweifel es gibt, je mehr Fragen es gibt, berechtigte Fragen von den Abgeordneten.
Der Regierung et cetera, desto länger wird es dauern, weil langsam kommt an
dass das, was da möglicherweise drinsteht oder das, was gefordert wird, alles andere als eine gute Idee ist.
Bei der SPD aus so, hast du da irgendeinen Eindruck?
Ja die SPD war lange unentschieden aber inzwischen.
So aus, äh dass äh die SPD äh das Leistungsschutzrecht äh ablehnt.
Aha. Immerhin.
Da gibt's heute auch noch eine Nachricht bei Punkt Info dazu.
Noch nicht, aber ne? Die ich war grade.
Ich, genau, genau.
Gut, die verlinken wir dann aber auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Genau, die wird parallel hier im Zimmer nebenan produziert gerade.
Wunderbar. Philipp, ich würde sagen, wir danken dir an dieser Stelle für die wirklich ausführlichen Informationen, die du uns zu dem Thema hier liefern konntest.
Aber gerne, immer wieder.
Ist also das ist jetzt quasi dein Urheberrecht, aber wir haben ja jetzt das Leistungsschutzrecht daran, ne? Insofern wird sich dann meine Sekretärin nochmal mit dir in Verbindung setzen wegen der Abrechnung.
Genau und ich schicke dann die Rechnung.
Und ich schreibe dann noch eine an Google oder so, müssen wir mal gucken.
Das holen wir uns alles bei der CDU wieder.
Das ist eine ordentliche Wertschöpfungskette, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das das kurbelt die Wirtschaft wieder an. Da passiert was.
Wir müssen das öfter machen.
Mach mal gerne Philipp, wenn sich da auch wieder was Neues ergibt, dann fragen wir auch gerne mal wieder nach. Ansonsten, wer sich da regelmäßig informieren will, Info. Vielen Dank.
Danke, tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.
Ja, das äh bringt uns dann zum zweiten Thema des Tages. Wir bleiben in einem
ähnlichen Bereich, würde ich sagen, zumindest hat es mit Google zu tun. Google hat ja äh Ankündigungen getätigt. Ähm,
rundum die Datenschutz äh Erklärungen, die sie so von sich geben. Was ist da jetzt eigentlich neu?
Also.
Ähm es war ja immer so Google bietet eine ganze Menge
Dienste an, denen gehören ja, was weiß ich, Google Analytics und äh YouTube und das sind viele, vielerseits äh Dienste, die sich ja auch irgendwie dazu gekauft haben und da mussten sie
teilweise dann eben auch deren
Datenschutzrichtlinien äh übernehmen oder haben sie einfach übernommen. Also ich glaube, dieses Google Analytics war ja auch mal vorher irgendein anderer Dienst oder Feedback und was sie alles haben und alle diese Dienste haben irgendwie unterschiedliche.
Ähm Datenschutzrichtlinien gehabt und das war Google ähm laut einem sehr schönen Werbevideo, was sie jetzt veröffentlicht haben, ein bisschen zu unübersichtlich und um es für den Nutzer sehr viel einfacher zu machen.
Wollen sie jetzt dafür sorgen, dass bei allen Diensten eine einheitliche Datenschutzvereinbarung gilt. Ähm.
Damit geht, was also in diesem Video sich noch sehr schön anhört. Damit geht aber ein sehr wichtiger Schritt für Google einher, denn zuvor hat Google immer versprochen, ja, dass sie,
die Daten, die unter den einzelnen verschiedenen Diensten,
anfallen, nicht miteinander in Verbindung bringen.
Ich war da, glaube ich, das muss zweitausendzehn gewesen sein. Da habe ich auch mal.
Ortrag oder so einen kleinen, ja, es war wahrscheinlich eher so ein kleines,
Lobby-Treffen mit ähm Alma Witten, der Datenschutzbeauftragten von Google,
sucht, das war so ein ganz kleinen Röntgen bei Schnittchen und da hat sie dann ähm erzählt, ähm,
wie sie also bei Google für für den Datenschutz sorgt und dass sie ja alles nach anderthalb Jahren löschen und äh die wie sie die Suchanfragen anonymisieren und solche Dinge.
Und dann hat sie eben auch mir erzählt, wie sie.
Genau das machen, dass sie also die Daten von den verschiedenen Diensten trennen. Und das war eigentlich schon immer eine Sache, die.
Die man sich technisch nur sehr, sehr schwierig vorstellen konnte, weil beispielsweise ähm.
Wenn ich jetzt meine E-Mails online lese bei Gmail.
Dann äh werden da ja rechts Werbung, wird der Werbung eingeblende.
Und diese Werbung ist ja mit mit Wörtern,
oder die ergibt sich aus Wörtern, die in diesen E-Mails stehen.
Google garantierte aber in gewisser Form wohl eine getrennte,
dieser Daten, sodass kein Profiling, also einerseits findet wohl ein Profiling meiner Person statt,
mir immer bessere Werbung zu liefern. Aber dieses sollte irgendwie getrennt sein von,
den Inhalten meiner privaten E-Mails und als ich sie dann bat das mir mal ein bisschen genauer zu erklären, konnte sie mir auch nicht im Detail nennen.
Wie das jetzt quasi auf obwohl es auf dem gleichen Server stattfindet, wie das sinnvoll getrennt wird, dass sie nicht diese Daten tatsächlich analysieren könnten. Ja, sie haben nur immer gesagt, sie machen es nicht. Das heißt, man hatte bis jetzt immer.
Nur das Vertrauen in Google, dass sie es nicht tun würden. Ähm.
Mit der neuen Datenschutzrichtlinie, da finden sich dann so Formulierungen drin, dass sie sagen ähm.
Moment, da hab ich möglicherweise
erfassen wir gerätespezifische Informationen und Standortdaten und unter Umständen werden,
personenbezogene Daten aus verschiedenen Google-Diensten miteinander verknüpft. Und das also eine etwas sehr.
Ähm sind sehr vage Formulierungen.
Den wohl einhergeht, dass Google jetzt sagt, wir wollen ähm.
Einfach mal alles, was wir haben, diese Daten zusammenfassen, aggregieren und dazu nutzen, dir bessere Dienstequalität bieten zu können und,
bessere Werbung. Das heißt also, sie nehmen das in ihrem Werbevideo, was wir auch verlinken, nennen sie das so, wenn du dann einen Jaguar suchst, dann dann wissen wir,
ob du ein altes äh Apple-Betriebssystem, eine Raubkatze oder ein Auto meinst.
Und zwar wissen wir das, was weiß ich, weil du vielleicht bei YouTube seit Jahren nur Katzenvideos postest oder weil wir äh
in deine weil wir in deinen E-Mails irgendwie lesen, dass du dich für für,
interessierst und zwanzig Autonewsletter abonniert hast oder was auch immer.
Mit den E-Mail, dass wir in deinen E-Mails lesen willst, also das, das, das.
Szenario. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es dass es da nochmal einen gewissen Ausschluss gibt in diesen.
Aber das ist also das, was Google jetzt machen möchte. Und sie möchten, denke ich,
ähm einerseits den Datenschatz, den sie da ohnehin haben und den sie.
Mit Sicherheit ähm.
Heben wollen würden.
Genau, mit dem sie sicherlich wahrscheinlich auch hinter verschlossenen Türen schon mal so ein bisschen rumgespielt haben. Ähm.
Wollen sie jetzt auch mal eben wirklich im vollen Potenzial ausnutzen. Und ich denke, dass das auch eine Reaktion auf ähm Facebook ist, weil Facebook ja sehr, sehr ähm.
Sehr, sehr mit sehr viel.
Sage ich mal, freizügigeren Datenschutzrichtlinien seinen Nutzern begegnet und da sehr viele Informationen sammelt und ähm.
Auch zur Anwendung bringt. Dass Google sich jetzt entschieden hat, okay, das müssen wir auch machen, wenn wir auf dem Markt, der,
des Verkaufens unserer Nutzer äh oder das zu Geld machen, zu unserer Nutzer ähm irgendwie Bestand haben wollen.
Ja, ich glaube,
träumt schon so ein bisschen davon, genauso schlagkräftig zu sein wie Facebook. Der Vorteil von Facebook ist natürlich, es ist alles in einem System, es war schon immer alles miteinander verbunden, ne, auch
Facebook muss man ein bisschen kämpfen, da die Regel noch ein bisschen so zu erweitern, wie sie das jetzt für angemessen halten, aber da sind sie ja auch recht erfolgreich dabei.
Bei Google war sicherlich gerade diese Konsolidierung dieser Dienste stand dem zunächst einmal im Wege. Das ist das, was sie jetzt versuchen, da anzugehen
der anderen Seite haben sie sich ja schon immer damit gepriesen, auch so ein bisschen offener zu sein, ja, also man muss nicht eingeloggt sein, um irgendwie an diese Informationen ranzukommen, wie lange so,
noch ähm Bestand haben wird, das wird sich zeigen
Ähm ob das dann auch für sie so erfolgreich sein wird, steht auch nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt, brauchen sie aber jetzt auch an der Stelle auch nicht weiter zu interessieren. Fragt sie natürlich, was sind so die kurzfristigen Auswirkungen davon und was ist jetzt
im Rahmen dieser jetzt durchgezogenen Konsolidierung,
eine konkrete Bedrohung vielleicht für den Einzelnen, die so vorher ausgeschlossen werden konnte.
Also ich würde ja sagen, ausgeschlossen werden konnte die Bedrohung auch vorher nicht. Wenn irgendwo Daten anfallen, dann fallen sie an und das da darüber sollte man sich bewusst sein und ähm.
So ist es nun einmal. Ähm was jetzt also erstmal
kurzfristige Reaktionen waren, ist, dass sich wirklich international äh sehr viel Kritik daran
breit gemacht hat, was Google da gemacht hat. Vor allem, weil sie ähm ja jetzt eigentlich keine andere Gelegenheit gegeben haben, als dem wirklich zuzustimmen.
Ähm.
Es gab dann sofort eine oder ein relativ kurzer Folge eine Abmahnung vom Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, der also sagt, weil das,
also der der deswegen abmahnt, weil diese neue Datenschutzvereinbarung einerseits zu unbestimmt und zu einem unangemessenen Nachteil der Nutzer führt.
Und haben jetzt gesagt, sie verlangen bis zum dreiundzwanzigsten März eine Unterlassungs,
klärung. Dann hat sich auch äh Ilse Eigner,
wieder zu Wort gemeldet und und das kritisiert. Jetzt wird man natürlich sehen wie weit Ilse Eigner und der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband in ihrem Kampf gegen Kugel.
Da kommen. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass Google.
Äh nach alter Manier erstmal größtenteils ignorieren wird.
Beziehungsweise da jetzt nicht großartig ähm.
Drauf eingehen wird, wäre jetzt so meine meine Erwartung erstmal, kann kann ich mich auch mit täuschen, es gibt sicherlich auch einige Zeichen, die oft deuten, dass das Facebook, äh dass Google solche ähm.
Reaktionen auf jeden Fall ernster nimmt als Facebook es macht. Bei Facebook landen die ja im Briefkasten, da passiert einfach nichts.
Gab's denn auf europäischer Ebene irgendeine Reaktion? Ich meine, was Deutschland macht, ist ja immer so das eine.
Ich, mir fällt jetzt spontan keiner ein, aber es gab bestimmt einer. Google äh fällt dir einer ein, aber es es.
Ich habe nur so den die Erinnerung grade, dass ich da was
dass da was an mir vorbeigeflogen ist, kann mich kann aber jetzt auf nichts konkretes zeigen.
Also in Europa soll's auf jeden Fall geprüft werden. In Frankreich ähm gibt's dann auch äh.
Sage ich mal, eine ein Bestreben, sich das mal genauer anzuschauen,
Ähm und es gibt auch, also.
In Frankreich sagen also Datenschützer, dass sie davon ausgehen, dass äh diese neue Datenschutzrichtlinie von Google auch im ähm Widerspruch zu europäischen Gesetzen steht.
Mhm. Ja genau, sowas hatte ich, glaube ich, auch gelesen, aber das ist halt alles noch sehr unklar
Na gut, auf jeden Fall sollte man äh sich vielleicht dann auch selber nochmal über die Nutzung von Google äh Gedanken machen bei Netzpolitik, Org wurde äh empfohlen, die History doch zumindest schon mal zu löschen, wenn man da keinen gesonderten Wert legt, dass sie bei Google gespeichert wird.
Aber das das habe ich den diesen Artikel, den habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden, weil Webhistory ist so ein Dienst, den musste man ohnehin aktivieren.
Und äh ich meine, wer sagt, okay ich ähm möchte, dass Google meine meine äh mein,
Seitenverlauf speichert, ähm dem ist jetzt auch nicht mehr zu helfen, wenn er das dann äh,
vorm ersten dritten irgendwie gelöscht hat,
Also was noch damit einherging, warum man das, wenn man es machen wollte, auf jeden Fall vorher hätte machen müssen, ist, weil mit in Kraft treten dieser neuen äh Datenschutzvereinbarung eben dann auch neue ähm.
Verwahrungs.
Zeiten für die Daten einhergehen, die natürlich alle ein bisschen länger sind und also insgesamt alles so ein bisschen natürlich gegen den Datenschutz. Ähm und es wird also, sage ich mal, zunehmend.
Vielleicht äh weniger Aluhut kompatibel Google Dienste zu nutzen. Wenn es das denn überhaupt jemals war, also ich ich habe das eh immer ein bisschen anders gesehen.
Ich mein, wenn Google zum Beispiel mit acht acht diesen schönen schnellen DNS-Server anbietet, das machen sie ja nicht, damit ich irgendwie, damit ich ein spannendes Internet habe, sondern weil sie möglichst.
Frische Daten, gute Daten darüber haben wollen, welche Seiten weltweit gerade besucht werden, um dadurch ihre ähm ihre Suchergebnisse zu verbessern und sich ähm besser zu positionieren. Insofern denke ich, dass man.
Also Datenschutz ist sicherlich eine nicht zu verachtendes oder wichtiger wichtige,
wichtiger gesetzlicher Bereich, aber eine allgemeine,
informiertheit darüber, dass Daten anfallen, ähm sollte beim Nutzer dann eben auch vorhanden sein.
Gut, wir äh beobachten das. Ähm ansonsten gab's noch Aktivitäten auch äh in Deutschland bestehende Fehler aufzuarbeiten.
Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag.
Eine der Zungenbrecherischerin äh Abkürzungen der letzten.
Monate wird wieder aufgerollt.
Ja sind eine Novellierung des Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrags steht ja schon wirklich seit langer Zeit an. Und das kochte zuletzt so
hoch ungefähr zweitausendzehn war das war das das große Thema. Ähm da ging's also um den Jugendmedienschutz Staatsvertrag und da geht es also darum
oder in der Novellierung, sage ich mal, der Teil, der jetzt das Netz interessiert, da geht's natürlich noch ein paar andere Sachen, aber der Teil, der das Netz äh betrifft, da ging es also darum,
irgendwie Jugendschutz im im Internet zu etablieren. Und man könnte sich jetzt also.
Überlegen, in, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel in die USA schaut, dann ist Jugendschutz eine Sache,
da gibt es Anbieter für. Da gibt's also sehr viele.
Anbieter, die irgendwie
was weiß ich. Da gibt's ja auch sehr viele Religionen in den USA. Ja, da geht's ja nicht nur um Jugendschutz, sondern dann eben auch darum, dass das Internet,
dass man nur Internetseiten sieht, die irgendwie religiös äh akzeptabel sind und so. Und da gibt's also eine eine ganze Menge Filterprogramme,
man sich da installieren kann, um sich vor dem Bösen oder seinen Nachwuchs vor dem Bösen im Internet zu schützen. Und ähm wenn ich also so ein Filterprogramm.
Programmieren möchte, habe ich eigentlich zwei einfache Ansätze. Entweder ich sage, okay, ich mache den Blacklisting-Ansatz, das heißt, ich führe eine Liste mit den Inhalten.
Die ich nicht zeigen möchte, also mit den bösen Inhalten.
Habe ich natürlich die Gefahr, dass ich niemals alle bösen Inhalte im Internet finden kann und meinen Filter in dieser Form löchrig sein wird. Oder ich führe eine Inhalte, die ich zeigen möchte.
Und sperre alles andere.
Also, das heißt, ich habe da eine Liste, da steht drauf, was weiß ich, Logbuch, Netzpolitik DE darf man besuchen,
DE darf man besuchen und den Rest äh macht da, den Rest sperren wir.
Beide Ansätze haben natürlich das Problem, dass sie eben entweder löchrig sind oder zu restriktiv.
Und das Internet ist bei weitem zu groß, um mit einem dieser Ansätze wirklich,
ich mal befriedigende Ziele zu erreichen. Und.
Als eine Klausel dieser Novellierung im Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag zweitausendzehn, der damals angestrebten, sah vor, die Nutzer zu verpflichten,
nicht die Nutzer, sondern die Betreiber von Webseiten zu verpflichten, quasi als Meta-Tech, als als unsichtbaren Teil in der Webseite.
Eine Alters äh Stufung vorzunehmen. Und in dieser Form dann,
sage ich mal, in Form eines offenen Standards ist dann
anderen Programmen diesen Jugendschutzfiltern zu ermöglichen entsprechend die Seite zu filtern, also zu erkennen, hier steht ab sechzehn mein Nutzer ist aber vierzehn, deswegen darf der jetzt diesen,
diese Seite nicht besuchen oder diesen Artikel nicht sehen oder was auch immer.
Das war so ein bisschen der Ansatz. Ähm.
Man könnte also sagen, im auf den ersten Blick vielleicht gar nicht so blöd. Ähm
Anderseits muss man natürlich auch erkennen, dass das ähm eigentlich nur eine,
Starthilfe oder eine eine wirkliche gesetzliche Investitionshilfe für Hersteller von äh Jugendschutz
Software ist, um denen Arbeit abzunehmen. Denn mit einer falschen Kennzeichnung oder einer nicht Kennzeichnung, äh der Seite ging dann Sanktionen einher.
Ähm und sage ich mal, als ein größeres kommerzielles Angebot,
natürlich nicht wirklich leisten, mehrfach gegen den Jugendschutz zu verstoßen, weil ich irgendwie ein Artikel über Brustkrebs ab zwölf eingestuft habe, aber dann war halt eine nackte Brust drauf und deswegen hätte der ab sechzehn sein müssen,
so dass da eine Industrie entstanden entstehen sollte,
quasi Zertifizierungen vornimmt, also den den Jugend,
Schutzeinschätzungsdienst.
Man dann für seine Seite schafft und der dann sagt, ja wir verleihen dir jetzt Prädikat.
Zwölf oder so und damit hast du eine gewisse Rechtssicherheit. Äh dass du selber jetzt nicht,
falsche Einschätzung vornimmst und dafür eine Abmahnung kritisierst oder so.
Dann wurden auch noch Öffnungszeiten debattiert,
bestimmte Seiten irgendwie, wenn sie denn ab achtzehn sind und nicht gekennzeichnet sind, dafür sorgen müssen, dass sie irgendwie erst ab zwanzig Uhr oder ab einundzwanzig Uhr zu sehen sind, ähnlich wie der Tatort in der ARD-Mediathe,
äh den kann man sich also morgens nicht anschauen, den gibt's erst nach zwanzig Uhr, weil ähm ist halt so. Ähm,
werden Nachtschicht arbeitet, hat eben Pech, kann kein Tatort gucken. Ähm da gab's also eine ganze Menge etwas unausgegorener Ideen,
und äh entsprechend formierte sich da ein sehr großer, sehr breiter Protest. Und es war eigentlich ein ein langer Krimi.
Bis dieser JMSTV dann tatsächlich äh scheiterte. Das kann man nachlesen,
in der in dem in der Chronik bei Netzpolitik ORG oder auch bei bei Wikipedia. Ich hab die beiden Dinge mal verlinkt.
So, das ist also jetzt die Erfahrung. So, man man hat sich wirklich mit diesem Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrau,
die sich über die Parteien zusammengesetzt und wirklich Mühe gegeben und gesagt, jetzt machen wir hier,
toll Jugendschutz, da wollen wir doch wirklich mal ähm uns auch irgendwie da können wir nur gewinnen, ja,
und am Ende hatten sie den, hatten sie den den Riesenprotest da. Und jetzt langsam, trotzdem,
sind alle unzufrieden mit dem aktuell geltenden Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag. Ich glaube, der ist so von zweitausenddrei.
Und es ist klar, dass jetzt irgendwie ein neuer Versuch in Richtung dieser Novelle gemacht werden muss.
Und da hat jetzt der Medienpolitische Expertenkreis der CDU.
Ein Positionspapier veröffentlicht, in dem so ein bisschen die leeren aus der Protestwelle zweitausendzehn gezogen werden.
Und äh das ist also sehr, ein sehr amüsantes äh Stück wieder, was es nicht,
schwierig machen wird, den den Protest gegen ein eine JMS-TV-Novelle wieder.
Wieder zu entfachen, nämlich sie wollen jetzt.
Quasi weil alle, die sich beschwert haben, das haben sie, hat die CDU ja richtig erkannt, die kamen so ein bisschen aus der Blockszene. Die Blogs haben den JMS-TV gestürzt und deswegen soll es also jetzt ähm.
Neben den Altersstufen sechs zwölf, sechzehn und achtzehn noch die Altersstufe B für Blocks geben.
Ja und dann ist alles gut.
Was soll das denn sein?
Ja und dann kann man also dann kann man quasi.
Dann habe ich als Blog nicht mehr das Problem, dass ich mich ab sechs, zwölf, sechzehn oder achtzehn einstufen muss und äh vielleicht die.
Dabei ein eine Fehleinschätzung vornehme, ja, seine Fehleinschätzung ist ja ein in mehrfacher Hinsicht fatal. Wenn ich.
Zu jung einschätze, dann begebe ich mich irgendwie in gesetzliche Schwierigkeiten, kann also abgemahnt werden,
oder was auch immer. Wenn ich's aber zu hoch ansetze, dann verliere ich natürlich potentielle Leser, weil ich irgendwie was weiß ich, die gesamte Jugend ausschließe.
Ähm das heißt, ich möchte also eigentlich sehr genau,
richtig einstufen. Und das ist natürlich von den vielen, vielen Bloggern in Deutschland eigentlich einfach nichts zu erwarten, dass sie es hinkriegen. Und jetzt sagt die CDU, dann macht doch einfach ein B.
Und ähm.
Dann könnten, das wäre dann grundsätzlich erst mal ab achtzehn, aber dann können Eltern äh das irgendwie für ihre Kinder einschalten und sagen, okay, mein Kind darf aber Blogs lesen.
Bist jetzt alt genug für Blogs.
Du bist jetzt alt genug für Blogs.
Aha. Das Kindergartenblock ist dann auf einer äh Augenhöhe mit mit Flashboard.
Ja, also.
Mit der Bloggerkennzeichnung und dann haben sie noch irgendwie eine Idee, ob man das eventuell Crowd-Sourcing da könnte die Netz-Community hätte vorgeschlagen, man könnte das Crowd-Sourcen.
Das ist aber nur irgendwie ein Nebensatz, dass sie sagen, dann sollen die Blogger das eben unter sichen, dann hast du wahrscheinlich noch den, den Alterseinstufungsbutton neben dem Flatter und dem Twitter-Button. Also.
Was soll man dazu sagen?
Ist schwer.
Schlagen vor, jetzt soll dann soll die Netz-Community sich doch selber kontrollieren. Ähm ja, also
wie gesagt, es ist eigentlich ein Trauerspiel, weil es zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatten sie ja noch also schon vor schon zweitausendzehn hatten ja alle, die dafür auch Lobby betrieben haben, die hatten ja noch nicht mal diese Jugendschutzprogramme, die funktionieren
die hatten sich ja noch nicht immer die Mühe gemacht, überhaupt erstmal äh da irgendwas zu,
können, ja, wenn sie jetzt wenigstens mal einen vernünftigen Schritt machen würden oder so. Also es ist wirklich eine.
Eine ganz ganz traurige Sache und ein weiterer Kritikpunkt, den ich bis jetzt noch gar nicht genannt hatte, war natürlich, selbst wenn man so einen Jugendmedienschutzvertrag, wie er zweitausendzehn
Plant war, etablieren würde und sagt, okay, in Deutschland sind jetzt alle verpflichtet, in Metatext, so eine Alterseinstufung vorzunehmen. Und selbst wenn das dann alle machen
Ja, was man natürlich nach vielen, vielen Jahren dann eventuell auch irgendwann hinkriegt, weil es gibt ja auch unendlich Leichen im Internet an allen HTML-Seiten, um die sich keiner mehr kümmert. Aber selbst wenn das dann alle machen würden, das deutsche Internet hat also jetzt sein Meta-Tag mit der Alterseinstufung
Was ist mit dem Rest der Welt? Ja und da ging es dann nämlich darum.
Es wurde dann auch beim äh JMS-TV debattiert, da eventuell mit Sperrverfügung oder sonstigen Sachen irgendwie zu begegnen, da gab's ja so einen bunten Reigen interessanter äh und abstruser Ideen
und ähm wenigstens davon hat die CDU jetzt auch ähm.
Abstand genommen und gesagt, ja, das wäre also wahrscheinlich nicht realistisch und da müsste man dann äh sagen, äh dass das wahrscheinlich auch der Meinungsfreiheit.
Widerspricht. Also man könnte eigentlich sagen, in diesem Positionspapier haben sie.
Sie mal hingehört und versucht zu sagen, okay, dann ähm hören wir mal, was was die Netzcommunity uns gesagt hat und dann machen wir mal irgendwie einen neuen Vorschlag, wo wir das irgendwie versuchen mit aufzunehmen.
Natürlich jetzt die Frage, was eigentlich die ähm wirklich kreativen Eingaben sein werden, weil nicht alles, was sich da jetzt in der Gegenrede gehört habe, macht im gleichen Maße Sinn, keine Ahnung, wo dieser Crowd-Shooting-Ansatz äh herkommt, aber so richtig durchdacht
zu sein scheint mir das äh auch nicht so richtig. Die Grundfrage ist natürlich überhaupt
überhaupt so eine Sperrung und so eine so eine Einstufung haben, will man eigentlich solcher Filtersoftware überhaupt da äh.
Wort reden, wo wo es da überhaupt Kompromisspotential in der ganzen Debatte.
Also ich habe in diese ich habe in dieser in dieser Angelegenheit ja so ein bisschen eine gespaltene Meinung. Ich ähm.
Weiß, dass Jugendschutz sicherlich ähm irgendwie in in gewisser Form.
Eine wichtige Bedeutung zukommt. Gerade irgendwie im Internet, wo wo es auch sehr viel,
sehr viel Unsinn gibt. Andererseits kann ich als ein Kind, was mit.
Eigenen Internetanschluss äh aufgewachsen ist und ähm ohne irgendwelche Kontrolle da häufig auch sich Zugang verschafft hat,
von mir behaupten, dass ich jetzt keinen ernstzunehmenden Schaden persönlich feststellen kann. Vielleicht stellen andere denen fest, ich persönlich äh halte mich für einen halbwegs
ganz gut gedienenen Menschen, andererseits also es ist es ist natürlich ein wirklich ein ein sehr,
gefährliches Thema und man will ja jetzt auch nicht als Kritiker eines JMS-TV will ich jetzt nicht auf eine Stufe gestellt werden mit jemanden, der sagt, ich möchte, dass ähm Kinder und Jugendliche unbedingt zu allen möglichen Quatsch, den es da im Internet gibt
ähm ein uneingeschränkten Zugang bekommen beziehungsweise würde behaupten, dass das jetzt äh der Entwicklung dienlich wäre,
Also es ist wirklich ein ein schwieriges Thema. Ähm ich kann nur natürlich erkennen, wenn.
Wenn man sagt, ähm Jugendschutz ist den Leuten wichtig, dann frage ich mich.
Warum es keinen kein ernstzunehmenden Markt in Deutschland für solche Jugendschutzsoftware gibt. Warum.
Macht sich keiner die Mühe,
einfach mal einen vernünftigen Jugendschutzfilter zu machen, ja, in Jahren, die wir jetzt über eine JMS-TV-Novelle debattieren und irgendwie den, den, den, den Inhalteanbietern, dass die Pflicht aufs Auge drücken wollen
ihre ähm in Sinne einer FSK sich irgendwie äh selber da einzuschätzen,
warum haben wir nicht wie in den USA einfach schon Filtersoftware? Und wahrscheinlich haben wir sie und sie kauft keiner. Da muss man sich natürlich auch fragen, warum kauft sie denn keiner?
Also der der beißt sich das irgendwie so ein bisschen in den Schwanz, weil du gerade noch zu dem fragtest, also in diesem Text, den in diesem,
Positionspapier steht dann einfach drin ähm den Satz kann man gut kurz zitieren. In Zukunft sollen die Blogger dann eigenverantwortlich,
Reputation der Kennzeichnung B hoch halten, indem sich die Szene selbst reguliert, zum Beispiel durch das Instrument des. Damit würde ein Vorschlag der Netz-Community unterstützt werden. Punkt weiter.
Zensiert euch dort gegenseitig.
Was ich besonders lustig und und absurd daran ist, dass ist so diese Wahrnehmung, es würde sich jetzt bei Bloggern in irgendeiner Form äh um irgendeine,
ähm Uniforme, Masse handeln, ja, die
da gemeinsam agiert, gleiche Interessen hätte oder sich auch nur in irgendeiner Form von allem anderen im Internet deutlich abzeichnen äh könnte. Also es ist natürlich totaler Quatsch, weil ein Blog ist einfach ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Werkzeug und und und,
keine gesellschaftlich,
Größe. Ich meine an der Stelle äh muss man sich dann vielleicht auch in den letzten Jahren so ein bisschen selber in die Nase fassen, dass natürlich Blogging äh da schon auch immer so als als Kulturtrend ähm.
Angeführt wurde, was er natürlich auch war, ne, aber was natürlich an dieser äh Stelle überhaupt nicht greift. Also ist es,
ist sehr schwierig und ich meine äh grad so die Taxunomin, ja das das Schaffen von irgendwelchen äh Gruppen und und äh
Zuordnung, das das ist ja an sich im im Netz auch einerseits ein ungelöstes,
ja, auf der anderen Seite, also alle wollen das ja auch irgendwie, ja, wer Porno hat, will auch Porno drauf schreiben, damit er gefunden wird, wenn
Porno gesucht wird. Auf der anderen Seite will man sich da nicht beschränken. Also es ist ähm meiner Meinung nach derzeit auch ein technisch nicht wirklich lösbares
Problem und die ganze Debatte wird, äh, es, es ist zumindest schwierig zu führen, wenn man jetzt versucht, sie mit technischen Lösungen ähm,
anzugehen, ja? Äh.
Also du du bringst gerade ähm Porno ins Spiel. Das ist äh interessanterweise sind in diesen
ähm in diesen Lobbyvereinigungen quasi die, die den JMS-TV da in dieser Novelle irgendwie ein bisschen, sage ich mal, massieren und betreuen wollen, da sind auch ähm,
deutsche Anbieter zum Beispiel dabei, wie die Telekom, die so eine äh Erotik-Lounge unterhält, die wohl keine keine Sau wirklich kennt. Ähm weil.
Es ist mir,
als ich da mal ein bisschen zu recherchiert habe. Ich war da auch vor ein paar Wochen,
äh zum Safer Internet Day irgendwie in Potsdam bei so einer, bei so einer Podiumsdiskussion. Ähm,
Es gibt eigentlich keine wirklich ähm erfolgreichen deutschen Pornoseiten, die mir jetzt bekannt wären.
Und das liegt offensichtlich daran, dass sie unter dem aktuellen Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag ähm Schwierigkeiten haben, solche,
Solche Pornographieangebote irgendwie ernsthaft zu betreiben,
und deswegen haben die auch ein Interesse daran, dass sie eine Rechtssicherheit haben, ihre äh Produkte irgendwie vernünftig anbieten zu können und nicht irgendwie einer
Sendezeitbeschränkung oder sonstigen zu unterliegen. Das heißt, es ist sind hier nicht nur hinter diesen Novellen stecken jetzt nicht nur wild gewordene.
Kinderschützer oder ähm vielleicht irgendwie nicht ganz so mit den mit den Gepflogenheiten das Internet vertrauten ähm.
CDU-Politiker oder so, sondern auch tatsächlich wirklich kommerzielle Anbieter von.
Ugendschutzrelevanten Inhalten, die das also auch wollen. Das darf man also an der Stelle äh nicht vergessen. Die wollen also auch eine,
klarere Regelung, eine Rechtssicherheit haben, um ihre Inhalte ähm legale und vernünft,
vermarkten zu können, was was wozu ihnen im Moment ein bisschen die Hände noch gebunden sind.
Aber äh um nochmal schön diesen Satz, den möchte ich einfach noch kurz zitieren, Eltern sollen bei den Jugendschutzprogrammen das Alter ihrer Kinder einstellen und zusätzlich entscheiden können, ob auch Angebote mit der Bloggerkennzeichnung angezeigt werden dürfen, unabhängig von der eingestellten Altersstufe
Und dann weiter
jeden soll zum Schutz der Bloggerkennzeichnung untersagt werden, eindeutig unzulässige Angebote mit B zu kennzeichnen. Dazu soll eine eigene Selbstkontrolle für Blogs und Nutzer generierte Inhalte durch die Netz-Community organisiert werden.
Unglaublich, wie viel Blogs zählt für Zukunft? Ähm ich glaube, diese ganze Debatte äh muss noch ein paar Mal durch den Kakao gezogen werden, bevor da irgendwas brauchbares bei rauskommt.
Leider ist es aber, wie gesagt, es ist ähm.
Also was was ich nur noch mal so abschließend sagen möchte, bei bei all diesen hanebüchenen Vorschlägen, die da irgendwie so kommen und über die kann man ja auch lachen. Es ist und bleibt irgendwie leider doch ein ähm.
Irgendwie einen ernstzunehmendes,
Thema. Und ähm ich bedauere eigentlich in dieser, ich hab's bei der vergangenen JMS-TV-Debatte bedauert,
denke, das werde ich auch bei der jetzt kommenden wieder bedauern müssen, dass ähm.
Die an, die die Vorschläge, die da kommen, einfach eine eine ernstzunehmende Diskussion direkt im Keim ersticken. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, da wenn das jetzt dieser Aufschlag ist, ein ein B für Blocks und äh mach doch hier mit oder so. Ähm
Wenn eine Debatte schon so anfängt, dann muss man sich nicht wundern, dass äh ja, da einfach nur laut drüber gelacht wird und.
Da kommen wir halt letztendlich ähm führt das zu sehr fürchterlichen äh Ergebnissen. Ich habe auch jetzt irgendwie schon von der,
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das irgend so eine ähm junge Dame, die in einem die.
Von der ich da sogar auf dieses Podium eingeladen worden war, die ist dann wirklich irgendwann sehr, sehr böse, böse auf mich geworden, weil ich weil ich ihre Ideen immer so abgeschmettert habe und habe mich dann da irgendwie.
Auch angegriffen und äh das das wird dann eben sehr, sehr schnell ähm.
Ja, diese Debatten, die entgleisen, ich glaube, du hast das ja damals selber im Berliner,
Haus noch diese diesen Moderationsversuch gemacht, ne, wo Alva.
Alvar Freude hatte dann da einen Vortrag gehalten,
und es war noch einige weitere anwesende. Du hast gesehen wie da echt einfach zwei Diskussionen Standpunkte aufeinandergetreten sind, wo jegliche Kommunikation eigentlich,
ausgeschlossen war, weil man sich nur noch irgendwie äh einerseits den Vorwurf, also einerseits kam der Vorwurf, dass man irgendwie den Kindern schaden wolle. Von der anderen Seite kam nur das laute Lachen über die über die hanebüchenen Vorschläge. Also der der kommt,
ist wirklich ein Thema, was.
Ihr wollt nicht die Kinder schützen und ihr wollt nicht das äh Internet schützen? So, das ist immer äh der Widerspruch, der an der Stelle noch nicht so richtig ausgeräumt wurde.
Ja
Na gut, wir können das jetzt hier auch nicht äh abschließend klären, denke ich, aber ein Überblick über die Nachrichtlage haben wir mal wieder gegeben. Linus, ich denke, wir können jetzt hier auch zum Ende kommen, oder?
Ja, ich denke auch.
Das äh äh war's dann hier mit Logbuchnetzpolitik, die fünfzehnte Ausgabe. Ja und äh ich glaube, nächste Woche geht's wieder weiter, oder? Wir sind im Zeitplan, ne, ein bisschen.
Wir sind im Zeitplan.
Alles klar, dann sage ich tschüss.
Und auf Wiederhören.
Genau.